pour garder son statut de destination
favorite de pourvoyeur de grands
frissons disneyland paris va inaugurer
une nouvelle attraction la tour de la
terreur soit cm de haut qui reproduit un
hôtel délabré grâce à cette tour le pape
espère attirer plus de 20 millions de
visiteurs par an sensations fortes
garanties
reportage gély à beaumont et m'a dit
diawara décrit dès l'entrée du parc
à l'intérieur de ces tours de 54 mètres
de hauteur un ascenseur un peu
particulier tiff une chute à 45
kilomètres heure
si vite que pendant quelques instants
les passagers sont en état d'apesanteur
ça c'est innovant quand même une bonne
chute dans le vide
on a l'impression de tomber d'une grande
tour et ça c'est impressionnant après
trois ans de travaux plus de 60 millions
d'euros d'investissements un décor
entièrement reconstituée façon années 40
thème de cette attraction la quatrième
dimension un concept importé des états
unis la terre d'allah
a été réfléchi pensé avait il y à 12 ans
résultat aujourd'hui presque une heure
d'attenté malgré la pluie
de quoi relancer le walt disney studios
le second parc disney un peu à la traîne
en moyenne chaque personne dépenses 40
euros dans les boutiques de nouvelles
attractions pour plus de visiteurs 12
millions 500 mille entrées et qui
ensuite 12 millions us en 1900 mhz à 14
millions 500 mille entrées en 2007
vous voyez que la progression est tout à
fait significatif derrière disney les
autres parcs français réagissent astérix
et le futuroscope près partout si de
nouvelles attractions